Let's talk about the twelve hundred dollar
checks that people are increasingly anxious
to receive.
Understandably, Donald Trump's treasury secretary,
Steven Manoogian, said today, said yesterday
and today stimulus checks are coming in three
weeks.
Supposedly now the devil is in the details.
So we're going to go through those details
now.
The Senate, remember, has passed a two trillion
dollar stimulus bill.
The House hasn't yet passed it.
They're expected to pass it tomorrow, Friday.
Hopefully that happens.
Hopefully Trump signs it.
It's been wildly delayed about 10 days ago.
This could have been done of could could have
been done closer to two weeks ago.
Really?
Meaning if that had been done two weeks ago,
we would now only be one week from people
starting to get the money.
Instead, we are three weeks away, but that's
only for roughly half the people.
The other half are likely going to have to
wait three, four or five additional weeks,
meaning half of the folks who qualify for
the checks are likely two months from receiving
them.
Meanwhile, Trump wants everything reopened
in 18 days April 12th.
He wants to let it rip and have churches full.
Now, later, I'm going to tell you about the
unemployment numbers which have exploded biggest
week in new filing of unemployment in the
history of the United States.
The point is people need cash.
Here's Stephen Manoogian this morning on CNBC,
laying out the timeline.
Just now, it's Treasury Secretary Steven Utian
first.
Mr. Secretary, congratulations on the record
time you put this together today versus 2007,
2009.
When will the checks be in the mail?
Well, Jim, first of all, thanks for having
me back.
And I want to thank the Senate for their swift
action.
People literally worked round the clock for
five days.
OK.
So I apologize for interrupting, but so already
everyone's pretending this has happened so
quickly.
Manoogian is thinking the Congress and Trump's
think it is that the other thing we knew this
was coming six to eight weeks ago.
They could have started the framework for
this at that point in time.
It could have been done and signed ten days
ago.
But regardless, everybody pats each other
on the back.
We knew that.
We expected that.
It's bogus.
Let's continue to the to the meat of this
thing.
And the president and I and others couldn't
be more pleased with the absolute unanimous
support on a bipartisan basis to get this
done.
In regards to the checks I announced yesterday
from the White House press conference.
First, while most of these will be direct
deposit.
So we call them checks in the mail.
But most movie direct deposits.
It'll be within three weeks.
We are determined to get money in people's
pocket immediately.
So that will be within three weeks.
No issues with the house.
We don't have to worry about that.
Can we can they hold it up?
I would hope that the House passes this unanimously.
I've already reached out to the speaker and
to Kevin McCarthy on the sense of urgency.
The American workers and American public and
merican business.
They need the money now.
OK, so three weeks for most people.
Now, this is really important to understand.
If you don't have a bank account on file with
the government, with the IRS, from prior tax
returns, you're likely looking at three to
five additional weeks, meaning it could be
two months before you get your check or direct
deposit.
That's going to be discussed.
That's a different process that still has
to be figured out.
So the people in the three week bracket that
Steven Manoogian is referring to are people
who file tax returns either already for twenty
nineteen or you filed your 2018 taxes and
you had a refund which required you to or
gave you the option of putting in your bank
account info so that you got the refund via
direct deposit and that bank account is still
active if you meet that criteria.
You got a refund in the last two years and
the bank account you used is still active
then you are in the three week bracket.
OK.
That's estimated to be half of the people
that are eligible for the checks for the deposits.
The other 50 percent, it's gonna be a much
longer process.
And they're looking at anywhere from three
to five additional weeks from what I've been
reading so far.
So consider this sort of conflict that the
how incongruous all of these different things
are.
Trump is talking during his daily press briefings
like we've almost won the fight against the
so-called invisible enemy, the invisible scourge,
or scorch, as he calls it.
He wants to open things back up on April 12th.
He wants churches packed for Easter.
Meanwhile, in the best case, if the government
has your bank info on file, you will get your
twelve hundred bucks after Trump wants the
country reopened.
If they don't have your bank info on file,
you could be looking at three to five more
weeks.
Now, as far as if you're not up to speed on
the details, this is twelve hundred bucks
per person for income up to seventy five thousand.
It starts phasing out between seventy five
and ninety nine thousand dollars in income.
And then after ninety nine thousand dollars
it goes to zero.
The numbers are doubled for couples.
So if you have a couple.
The ceiling is one hundred and forty nine
K or one hundred and fifty thousand call it.
If one person makes one hundred and forty
eight thousand the other person makes a thousand.
As a couple you make one forty nine, you're
still under 150.
You still get twenty four hundred dollars
total twelve hundred each.
You also get five hundred dollars per child.
And then in addition to this, for folks who
are filing for unemployment benefits, the
federal government from assuming that the
House signs this, this is in the Senate bill.
What we have to assume that the House was
going to do the same thing.
The federal government will boost state unemployment
benefits by six hundred dollars a week.
That's huge.
There are states.
I know folks in some states in the Midwest
where the benefits are in the three hundreds
per week.
So if the benefits thrifts call it 375 a week,
another six hundred a week is literally the
difference between being able to afford your
necessities and not so that is a really big
deal.
But again, notice nothing lines up.
We have an incoherent timeline.
Many governors are extending stay home orders
into April.
Some of them are even going into May.
Trump says we're winning and we're reopening
on April 12th.
Half of the country is going to get checks
around April 16th.
The other half are looking at mid-May for
getting their checks or direct deposits.
And meanwhile, cases and deaths continue to
explode faster and faster in the U.S., accelerating
even beyond the growth that Italy and Spain
saw at their worst moment.
So we're not in good shape.
We're gonna deal later today with the unemployment
issue.
We're going to deal with the case rate and
a whole bunch of other stuff.
Despite all of the bad news, I am glad that
you're with us today.
Let me know your thoughts on what we've discussed
so far on Twitter.
I'm on Twitter at Deepak The David Pakman
Show
at David Pakman dot com.